hello and welcome to see you playing
Vlad took lot talk and another cheater
maybe a only it's like one or two games
and those okay
it's crazy it don't play that many
cheaters actually on each other I feel
but um it's not at least it's not a
difference like to to any other platform
or but Twitter role would have been
excessive really the opponent camp has
played the Trump with h4 it's lined and
always is yeah that is always given as
dubious by by theoreticians but I'm
never so sure I mean I don't think it's
fantastic for white but I'm really not
certain that it is actually terrible as
the theoreticians so sometimes suggest
it's it's murky at least very murky
those positions okay I'm trying to get a
night over to those weekend squares
really hmm that looks odd
okay if I take 27
there's night f2 I guess I'm taking it's
not really helping let's do this then a
tech g3
my cake coming to the seven and then
long for Luke h8 it doesn't look too bad
go to h8 wait if I take it is there some
way from medium there is no time there's
no immediate kill
hmm okay so let's go back and now I
wanted to call g5 I'm not sure this is
good actually
but I want to make sure that this Bishop
is doing something after f5 I have G
form okay so I'm going to take a guess
hmm my ship is still not really doing
all that much going maybe 95 from you
know
yeah Queen g8 was my gym or this one
this is actually not a bad idea trying
to trying to trade it and now maybe you
know it may be Queen h3 now now doesn't
help him that much Midas Queen h4 Knight
h5 try still trying to put more pressure
on that on that pawn yeah yeah I thought
97 should be fun isn't it like does it
take 90 for Jay King no taking is bad
or here this is okay come on I'm still
slow iam really too slow spending a bit
too much time on this I wonder if f5 is
something that I threaten now at five
yeah let's do it
check yeah I mean it's got to check
there only six but is that dangerous I
don't see it
it doesn't have d6s queen g8 what should
be fine for me so it seems like he wants
to go to g5 a check on b2 would be good
I'm going back to put this on to e7
simply blocking blocking okay now I can
go to the square and then to G 4G for
attacking this attacking f4 okay this is
a good move unfortunately
you know not happy with this I can take
c5 just like that it's one of those
games you should never lose yeah when
you're just better for nothing yeah okay
hmm
that was that was really kind of
unnecessary I mean like around here like
it's just fine well the engine doesn't
agree I really thought like here white
is in bad shape from yeah I mean anybody
I thought I'm better at the engine does
not agree got a weird game so yeah then
it seems it seems I that's not okay here
I can't just take a four okay and that
is easy in fact just grab this pawn hmm
no I didn't see that didn't see it at
all I was just focused on the kingside I
mean I really can't believe you just
can't give up the pawn like that it's
just like I'm just created better here
but yeah I didn't didn't do it do it
right 95 is a lot stronger and this is
actually this is an interesting moment
you know I was almost automatically
taking with this I'm not quite sure why
with hindsight but if you think about it
this is a much more this is a lot more
logical because if I can trade this I'm
trading his best piece and I don't need
six is clearly his best piece and my
knight year from d7 is is really not
going anywhere
good I don't have a good square to go to
or a clear way to improve but it's just
a passive piece and I should definitely
play this it was a pretty pretty
substantial mistake I mean the engine
still gives me an edge here okay but
this is a lot better just by pure logic
this is a lot better to activate the
piece and per possibly trade like him
the engine wants to click in the check
yeah okay just like it's so much better
this position without those two pieces
yeah this this night is a disaster yeah
I get here and I mean that's probably
just a win it's like - - well but this
is this is a bad decision it's bad to
sit where a lady takes makes it makes it
a lot more difficult to play I mean of
course I'm really not this is not a big
big debate that that I was clearly
better here but it gets tricky and I'm
not strong and I'd have to it's it's
kind of the only move anyway but I did
not see I did not see the queen bee five
thing and now Queenie ADA's is just like
blundering it away entirely Queen f7 is
still fine even though I've spoiled it
already but just like this is the the
moment of the game that is quite
instructive and I don't know that that
was a really bad move they're just so
much better trying to trade it okay
might will not trade but what is he
going to play them the engine suggests
screaming - as a possible alternative
and okay maybe taking Queenie sixes now
under on the agenda but should have six
suggested by the engine okay I can
always flick in Queen g8 this is a
really important time sorry Queen g8
check came back and now here and now
there is no check simply there is no
check I mean the engine is just like
very relaxed about the deep on like here
mean that's not so easy for a human
player but if you look at this is a
little bit more closely you will find
that this is not just not taking pay
part in the game now and that is really
interesting
I should really play night eggs and then
I blended it away step-by-step huntress
wasn't good it is a lot more
okay thanks a lot for watching